les accords de misc reviennent sur le
devant de la scène mais cette fois c'est
le secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken qui parle de la nécessité de
leur exécution
la diplomatie le seul moyen responsable
de résoudre cette crise potentielle si
la russie et l'ukraine renouent le
dialogue dans le cadre des accords de
minsk qui vise à mettre fin aux conflits
armés dans l'est de l'ukraine
victoria nuland vice secrétaire d'état
américain dit même qu'il n'existe aucune
alternative aux accords de minsk nous
pensons que les états unis peuvent jouer
un rôle de soutien comme nous l'avons
fait en 2014 2016 lorsque nous avons
remplacé le format normandie en
travaillant en parallèle avec kiev
je pense que nous sommes prêts à le
faire nous ne voyons pas d'autre
alternative que de commencer à faire
quelque chose et pas seulement discuter
des accords de minsk
ces fameux accords de misc conclu en
2015 dans le but de régler la situation
en ukraine comportait plusieurs volets
il s'agissait entre autres de mettre fin
à toutes les hostilités dans la région
d'obtenir le retrait de toutes les
forces étrangères de la zone du conflit
d'octroyer un statut spécial de semi
autonomie aux régions de donetsk est
lougansk est d'assurer le droit de la
population à utiliser la langue de son
choix pour les habitants de ces régions
majoritairement russophone ce dernier
point était des plus importants mais six
ans après la signature des accords rien
de tout cela n'a été accompli pire les
autorités ukrainiennes ont mobilisé
massivement leurs troupes dans la zone
du conflit sur la ligne de contact dans
le gambas les forces armées ukrainiennes
renforcent leur présence militaire en
transférant du matériel lourd et du
personnel
selon certains rapports le nombre de
militaires l'ukrainien dans la zone de
conflit a attend déjà 125 mille
personnes et pour ceux qui l'ignorent
cela représente la moitié des forces
armées de l'ukraine selon les missions
spéciales d'observation de l'eau et ce
en ukraine la violation du cessez le feu
et n'est plus enregistrées localement
mais sur toute la ligne de contact
les semaine dernière certains jours leur
nombre a dépassé les maximum enregistré
par la mission avant l'entrée en vigueur
des mesures supplémentaires visant à
renforcer le régime de cessez le feu du
22 juillet 2020
mais pour kiev c'est moscou qui veut
enterrer les accords de minsk je pense
que la russie sera très heureuse si les
accords de minsk échoue cela dégagerait
de toute responsabilité lui donnerait
toute liberté d'action
le format de normandie et les accords de
mises sont dans le coma mais ils sont
toujours en vie il faut essayer de les
réanimer
voilà qui contredit le président
ukrainien actuelle vladimir zielinski
qui dans une interview accordée au
financial times en avril dernier parler
de la nécessité de changer ou même
carrément d'abandonner le processus de
minsk il y a deux options nous pouvons
modifier le format de minsk l'ajuster où
nous pouvons utiliser un autre format
l'échec de la situation actuelle serait
également due à la france et à
l'allemagne selon le président russe
l'ukraine refuse ostensiblement de
respecter ses engagements concernant
l'ensemble de mesures de minsk tout
comme les accords conclus dans le cadre
du format normandie en paroles nos
partenaires du format normandie
l'allemagne et la france ne conteste pas
l'importance des accords de minsk en
passant il ne faut pas oublier que les
accords de minsk ont été consacrés en
tant que norme en droit international
une décision pertinente du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu a été adopté mais en
actes malheureusement il encourage la
politique du gouvernement actuel de kiev
axé sur leur démantèlement ce qui mène
malheureusement les négociations et le
règlement lui-même dans l'impasse
avec l'entrée en jeu des états unis on
verra si derrière les grandes
déclarations de la diplomatie américaine
se trouve une volonté réelle d'apaiser
les tensions dans l'est de l'ukraine